et pour parler de ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire allégée nous sommes avec
laurence comptes porte parole du
syndicat des directrices et directeurs
d'école directrice d'une école dans le
var merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france alors le
gouvernement qui le répète tout ce
nouveau protocole allégée est mise en
place pour simplifier la vie des
familles mais visiblement
c'est un avis que vous ne partagez pas
bonjour merci pour l'invitation d'une
part alors en effet on ne le partage pas
parce que ça va en effet simplifier la
vie des enseignants et des directeurs
d'école
pas spécialement celles des parents
d'une part parce qu'il ya une pénurie
d'autotest dans de nombreuses pharmacies
et celle de mon secteur en tout cas en
font partie et parce que les parents ne
se sentent pas de faire les les
autotests à leurs enfants alors
plusieurs cases sont fermés depuis la
rentrée quel est l'état des lieux dans
votre département ou en tout cas dans
votre école
alors dans mon école il ya eu pas mal
d'élèves positif de la première semaine
mais au niveau des contaminations entre
les familles donc il n'était pas revenu
à l'école donc on n'a pas enclenché de
processus de test massif pour toute la
classe il ya eu une élève positive
asymptomatiques dans ma classe hier donc
tous les éléments dû se faire tester
hier soir en tout cas ce qu'ils ont pu
trouver un test et qu'ils étaient
négatifs sont revenus ce matin donc ce
matin j'avais onze élèves au lieu de 24
parmi ces élèves d'ailleurs un qui n'est
pas revenue et positive et on a une
autre classe aussi pour l'accueil est
suspendu et tous les élèves doivent se
faire tester aussi trois fois coup sur
coup troisième changement protocole en
l'espace de dix jours certains
enseignants dénoncent des mesures trop
légère
qu'est ce que vous attendez précisément
du ministère de l'éducation du
gouvernement justement pour essayer de
de freiner voilà 7 celle de vagues dans
les écoles
alors soit le protocole est trop léger
en effet et c'est vrai que nous on
demande ce que ce qu'a proposé le
ministre depuis cet été c'est à dire un
cas positif une fermeture pendant sept
jours c'est ce qui était proposé cet été
et il a au plus la crise sanitaire se
développe au plus les mesures se
s'allège donc c'est vrai on est on est
quand même dans l'incompréhension les
parents aussi si on part du principe
qu'on doit laisser circuler le virus
dans les écoles ce qui est peut-être
d'un point de vue sanitaire l'idée de
deux certains médecins je ne sais pas
dans ce cas là le protocole est quand
même extrêmement contraignant donc en
fait là dans l'état actuel des choses il
ne il ne va pas et les enseignants ne se
sentent pas protégés n'ont pas
l'impression présent leurs élèves sont
protégés ni que la famille de leurs
élèves le soir alors certains syndicats
dénoncent que ce nouveau protocole ne va
pas dans l'intérêt de l'enfant mais
plutôt de maintenir les écoles ouvertes
est ce que vous partagez cet avis oui en
fait depuis la rentrée de janvier et
savait déjà vraiment commencé beaucoup
en décembre nous avons des classes avec
un nombre très aléatoire d'élèves les
élèves viennent reparte que ce soit dans
le premier degré d'ailleurs ou dans le
second degré on n'a jamais le même
nombre d'élèves est en fait on a des
conditions de travail extrêmement
dégradée donc nous on n'est pas pour une
fermeture des écoles à tout prix on est
pour faire en sorte que quand on est en
classe qu'on puisse travailler
efficacement avec nos élèves donc là
jusqu'à présent ça n'est pas le cas et
nous avons bien peur que ces nouvelles
mesures ne ne contribue pas à faire en
sorte en tout cas que la situation
sanitaire s'améliore dans les écoles
plusieurs syndicats d'enseignants ont
également appelé à la grève nationale
je dis est ce que vous serez dans la rue
pour justement demandé qu'on vous écoute
un dialogue en tout cas avec le
gouvernement parce que eux
finalement c'est encore une fois dans la
presse que vous avez pris connaissance
de cet allègement
exactement donc d'un bon prix plus les
différentes appris les différentes
mesures hier soir en regardant le
20h00 prix le dimanche 2 janvier les
mesures en tout premier lieu dans un
journal de surcroît payant avant d'avoir
la mise à jour de la faq contrairement à
ce qu'a dit le ministre ce matin sur bfm
d'ailleurs voilà nous avons les
informations toujours en dans un second
temps les parents et nous nous apprenons
en même temps les différentes
informations et les parents ne
comprenait pas ce matin au portail
pourquoi on appliquait pas dès ce matin
les nouvelles mesures
merci beaucoup en tout cas florence
content d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dont je rappelle que vous êtes porte
parole du syndicat des liens entre ces
directeurs et directeurs d'école
directrice également une école dans le
var